mihawk took sorrow in because of luffy
have you ever been so bored that you
went out of your way to start beef with
a yonko
well me neither however this guy has
mihawk is an incredibly interesting
character in the story for a number of
reasons as the strongest swordsman his
strength and position in the hierarchy
of the one piece world are probably one
of the most heatedly discussed topics in
the fandom at this point and while there
are probably just as many people who
find this debate pointless as those who
blow it way out of proportion
mihawk's power actually is a pretty big
part of his character because even
though he might not seem like the type
being one of the most stoic and serious
characters in the story mihawk has
actually a surprisingly interesting
character arc starting all the way back
at the baratier and coming to a close
with him taking zorro in as a
and student even though mihawk rarely
actively appears in the story he
actually plays a really important role
for one piece world building overall but
especially so for zorro and his journey
towards becoming the strongest swordsman
in the world so how did mihawk change as
a character during and after marine fort
how strong is he really what's the deal
with him and perona and will he ever
fight zoro and shanks again in the
future this is the story of the
strongest swordsman rival to shanks and
former warlord of the sea the story of
dracul mihawk
at his introduction early on in the
story mihawk serves as a signpost for
how strong people in the one piece world
truly are as a fellow warlord he
brilliantly sets the stakes for the
baroque work saga and the fight against
crocodile and i already talked a lot
about all the symbolism that is
associated with mihawk in my scene
analysis of his fight with zaro and
boratier so if you're interested in that
i suggest you check out that video
afterwards to sum it up though like most
swordsmen in the story mihawk has a very
strong religious theme going on giving
him the appearance of a spanish
inquisitor now this mostly serves to
show the duality of both his strong
dedication to his beliefs and creed
while at the same time highlighting his
violent unforgiving and strict side as
well just as the catholic church used to
be
during the inquisition
nobody expects the spanish inquisitor
now this creed that mihawk follows is
not christianity however but the bushido
the path of the samurai that zorro also
follows although approached through the
lens of buddhism while shanks represents
nordic mythology and its values and
beliefs long story short swordsmanship
and by that i mean real swordsmanship is
a sort of religion in the world of one
piece and only true believers and
followers can rise into the ranks of the
very best
and this serves as the framework for the
interactions and relationships that
mihawk has with both sorrow and shanks
all have quite different beliefs values
and powers but they all respect the
bushido and thus are worthy opponents
when it comes to sword fighting that is
and this is regardless of their actual
power level the reason why mihawk
suddenly started respecting zorro and
treated him as a worthy opponent is not
because zoro suddenly became as strong
as him but because he demonstrated his
will to follow the path of the swordsmen
all the way to death
and major spoiler alert from the manga
please skip ahead 10 seconds if you
aren't caught up yet
of course by dad will i also mean zaro's
congress hockey that mihawk most likely
saw when he used the 3 000 worlds
against him we actually have this really
short moment even in the manga as sora
launches his attack where mihawk is
clearly shocked by this reveal as it
serves as the ultimate proof of zoro's
will and potential to make it all the
way to the top so how is it that mihawk
went from seeing zoro as a potential
future rival to becoming his mentor
throughout the time skit for that let's
look at mihawk's surprisingly deep
character arc now writing a great
character arc is actually pretty damn
hard and as with all new skills you want
to learn it always helps having someone
explain it to you in great detail and
that is exactly what skillshare is all
about skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
covering pretty much any topic you might
ever want to learn about be it starting
a youtube channel or how you make your
very own manga i've personally been
using skillshare for quite some time now
mostly to improve my work here on
youtube but it can really be anything
for example i personally have really
enjoyed this course on knife skills by
elena carp recently so i can now slice
my onions in true mihawk fashion oh look
and there's even a class on
bladesmithing how fitting if you also
love learning new skills then you should
definitely give skillshare a try not
only is it pretty damn affordable with
under 10 bucks per month for an annual
membership but the first 1000 people to
use my link in the description below
will get a free trial of skillshare
premium so that you can try it out for
yourself but now back to my fellow knife
master
mihawk's perspective on the central
moral theme of one piece freedom is that
the best thing is to be a lone wolf
bound by no one and seeking out other
wolves to test his strength
or i guess in his case it's actually a
lone hawk one might even say he's a
mihawk
[Music]
now the major turning point for mihawk
was the war at marinefords before the
war we get introduced to him as an
extremely self-centered person he's
pretty much the only strong pirate out
there operating completely without any
crew or any other people supporting him
he is literally a one-man crew that
sails the seas bored out of his mind as
he has no one to test his ridiculous
strength on
this becomes especially clear in his
relationship with shanks regardless of
his ridiculous haki shanks was powerful
enough as a swordsman alone to spar
evenly with mihawk leading to the
legendary rivalry between the two no
doubt that mihawk came looking for
shanks quite often to have a duel but
when shang sacrifices his arm for luffy
and inspires him to become a pirate
mihawk doesn't care at all about his
motivations and the reasons he simply
sees shanks sacrificing his strong sword
arm as an insult with a rivalry and
doesn't even bother to draw his swords
against him
[Music]
shanks the only man who was ever able to
excite mihawk gave up on being a top
tier swordsman for a mere kit now given
that shanks has ridiculous hockey
abilities he probably doesn't care about
that though and their rivalry turns into
a sort of friendship
however while that was all nice and well
that now left mihawk with absolutely no
one to rival with and test his skills on
and he ended up so bored and aimless
that he chased after people like don
creek just to get a bit of a kick out of
it
[Music]
and i think it's pretty evident that
this self-centered person who only cared
about his own strength would never have
accepted zoro's show of throwing away
his pride as a swordsman by bowing to
him because this is essentially what
shanks did in mihawk's eyes as well and
so i think it comes as no big surprise
that this proud ridiculously powerful
swordsman despite becoming a warlord was
never really willing to follow the
directions of the world governments what
made the war at marine fort different
was not the fact that he was scared of
the world government's repercussions as
we just saw mihawk didn't really care at
all about losing his warlord title no
the reason he participated in this war
was because he would be able to
challenge white beards
the strongest man in the world versus
the strongest swordsman basically mihawk
went to marineford for a kick as well to
fight the only man he believed worth
fighting at this point and yet when he
showed his hand jozu shielded his
captain from his attack at this point it
begins to dawn on mihawk that whitebeard
wasn't only feared because of the beast
of a person he was
but also because of all the people he
had gathered around him and later the
very same thing happens again with luffy
deciding to test his resolve in power
again after already having taken a bit
of an interest in him at baratier more
and more of luffy's allies keep getting
in mihawk's way and i think it's at this
point that mihawk truly understands that
the ability of gathering strong allies
is the greatest power he's seen on the
seas
[Music]
and yet his mind doesn't change
completely here just yet when shanks
arrives to end the war he realizes that
there are no more worthy opponents left
to fight and he leaps shanks is the last
person he wants to fight after he ruined
the rivalry and of course to be fair
also because shanks as a yonko is most
likely still just out of his league when
he uses his hockey
and so things only really change from
mihawk after the war as zorro is
transported to his islands and it is
this interaction between them that
brings luffy's impact on mihawk to full
bloom zorro is the only character as far
as we know who mihawk hopes can grow to
one day challenge him and yet here zorro
is telling him that fighting for the
self-centered greatest swordsman pride
something that mihawk has only ever
cared about does no longer serve as his
motivation
wants to become the strongest swordsman
in order to help luffy become pirate
king and at first this clearly leaves
mihawk disgusted in a way he thinks that
zorro is weak and wasn't even strong
enough to beat all the monkeys on the
island that were trying to imitate him
by the way a really nice metaphor for
what he thinks of most other swordsmen
and he believed that zorro came asking
him for help to get off the island and
yet for the very first time these things
are now becoming more personal to mihawk
with added perspective when he sees that
zorro has easily beaten all the monkeys
and could leave whenever he wanted to
mihawk realizes that zorro is asking for
help for luffy's sake and not his own
which is why he agrees to train him
mihawk finally listens to zorro and
accepts his plea given that he's seen
that fighting for others is worthwhile
in its own right since luffy and
whitebeard fought for ace and in turn
many many people fought for them as well
ultimately making his presence at the
war more or less irrelevant especially
as he was never willing to go all out
anyways and so mihawk is now no longer
the lone wolf realizing that having
someone by your side to fight for is
what gives one true freedom and purpose
and so the fact that he lets perona and
zoro stay with him on this island for
two years forming real relationships for
the first time
is something that pre-war mihawk would
never have been able to do and
ultimately i believe that mihawk's
character arc would be fully completed
if he ever decided to spar with shanks
again